you de squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur pirate dating est chevalier
d'infoman c'est donc une sorte de
chevalerie médiévale warfare en version
gratuite pirates vikings chevalier les
pirates mon gars on va essayer les trois
ans commence par un perroquet j'ai
vraiment [ __ ] de perroquets ce génial
je vais envoyer mon plan qui va faire
des noces copé deschodt ben là bas dans
le cul tuer cet homme dont la base est
le gang des pirates tu vas faire quoi
gmail est gage fonce dans le tas et mon
staff on m'appelle super sabres hors de
la moité des soupes haderer des soucis
président doug au quasi gady gadoue
voilà et hop je deviens comme ça contre
le mur bat à
la hâte en médias adorent moquer j'étais
switch estime michael c'est à dire que
le gang différentes n'existe plus
au bouclier pc bon ça mais tu fais quoi
mais va chier ok j'ai eu ok on l'a eue
au quai à ok on va pas eu en place je
vais bien coup mais attend il a beaucoup
aimé ce pirate gones as tu joues tu as
pas sur son rocher c'est mon rocher
appelé carlos viens viens n'a aucun
termine pour être sauvé tu est destiné à
nourrir
[ __ ] on et aura bien le gars y'a pas
testicules a bien on est bien dans l'eau
on est bien on vient là bien là je sais
pas nager par contre j'ai une grosse
armure qui passe d'automne alors tu vas
être calmé mes mains c'est bon tu vas
faire quoi ben voilà bah ouais ben
cette flèche on m'appelle araud voilà
vous avez mon doigt ou d'irriguer kcc
comme fort brave la veille son perroquet
oh oui je vais faire moins 32 au pelage
temps [ __ ]
hopla -31 au flat -33 aux places est
mort
parce couleurs mais c'est quand même
fantastique vous avez tué trois ennemis
sur cinq se nourrir une seule fois je
vais de châtier mewen appelle-moi
monseigneur s'il te plaît surprise
plusieurs fucker c'est une blague voilà
c'est comme ça à condamner les aime les
ennemis regardez je trouve un spot pas
trop mal entre ces deux palmiers je suis
totalement invisible voyez cet homme
eh ben j'ai raté et me met mal mais car
toi m'a dit oh oh
moi j'ai toujours voulu être un pirate
mais l'équipe elle est pleine alors du
coup bas ne peut pas l'être auditop
heureux qu'un employé en plus c'est
effroyable quoi va sur ses démos il a
tué deux si ça se passera pas qu'ils
aient bat sais quoi je suis un viking au
haut débit fixe à deux armes c'est pas
dégueu bla bla blart r&d chien robot tu
as [ __ ] bonbons aux questions à faire
hop hop hop olala
c'est totalement no brain quoi serge et
à taper sur glee gauche et j'attends et
je fais des combos et bientôt il décède
voilà bien la satanée pirates tu ne
s'envolera pas au revoir parce qu'il
serait très très bien c'est qu'à chaque
couche et récupère 100 % de ma vie et
voilà c'est la fin
j'ai tué un perroquet je me barre dans
cette grotte sombre c'est une femme
les mecs joseph et 11 euros pendant une
minute toutes parties démentent ils ont
perdu leur bateau tout l'europe est ok
je suis pirates avec la longue carabine
mon gars qu'est ce qu'il fait
ok c'est pas
ce qu'on lui a dit qu'il veut se prendre
une balle à bout portant
et gros pénis non non non non non non
non non mais non mais non mais arrête
non mais t'es bête a pas du tout en fait
en fait c'est pas drôle un monde de
football de leur ca comment je vole aux
riches à tous aux habitations inard
gilet pare balle aille voilà oui oui ok
on teste le pirate au baril qui pète
attendait plus il faut que le test mais
j'espère que ça va se finir comme le mec
juste avant
ok je lance et ça
c'est pas mal à ta gueule
mais arrête je sais que tu veux le pool
et j'ai compris
aux mondiaux ça a pété
à la safer mal c'est mon pouvoir spécial
ailleurs je peux pas l'utiliser sur
cette terre ne peut pas être utilisé
sous l'eau à y avait eu plus de pitié
quoi le perroquet sépare des as pas
d'être vivant c'est une arme
ce qui n'est pas un peu con mon
perroquet et supra demande pas encore
a explosé le plan hockey oh [ __ ] ya
une arène ça ça va être bon ça c'est
quoi ce bordel pourquoi tout part en
vrille y'a d'la la surprise au revoir on
est tous avec nos tonneau comme déconne
ça pète ça pète
[Applaudissements]
j'attrape a coupé le pied a
alors lui manque de respect ou passes à
l'adversaire quand même illusion de
piété sur la tête quoi tout ça avec r d
ofer il se vautre pas
au revoir à temps il est pas mauvais
tueur direct mois là
haut c'est beau ce qu'ont les amis howie
tenebris puisqu isip égale la mouette et
des taupes à des techniques du tonneau
rager
mais je les tue et au moi ça m'a fait
peur aux qu'est ce qu'on rigole du don
sporting et brice tenebris quittant l'as
lattes et des bri qui a planté
littéralement du bout de son épée
l'ennemi oh oui ont la charge qui rate
il manque de tomber dans malades
attention cette fin deux roues des
taxations
âgées ok j'ai pu le voir mais je fait
des étincelles tu vas pas me tuer quand
je fais des étincelles c'est très
divertissant toiture petek pas mon grand
ma vie est nulle et des bri m'a dit je
te vous rendez cros
[Musique]
et où discutent du oui mais voilà les
gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
sur pirate vikings et chevalier 2
j'espère que vous a plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo comme
d'habitude c'est comme si vannes remedy
valoir fort en un petit peu moins bien
fait bien sûr mais moi c'est gratuit
donc c'est cool là cela va regarder en
sortir très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo tient deux mondes pis
[Musique]